it's so good to see here use unit
collector mania it's so good to see you
too three years three years it's been
it's shot by lots happened since then
haven't you this you've swapped passion
for piety in Game of Thrones what has it
been like being part of the faith
militant it's been amazing it's been
amazing to come back and first of all to
have such a different physical
appearance I was very I was overwhelmed
and I was shown the costume for the
first time I worked with the people that
made this costume when I was 13 on a
little under on a film idea call my
family they're animals so we went from
all these little jovial sweet lord
costumes too intense chains across your
chest and prosthetics going on across
your forehead it was uh it was wonderful
when I found out that this was what they
were going to do in lancel I was I was
terrified and exhilarated at the same
time yes because last time we talked I
remember saying any work might go in the
future new thinking would they do the
whole kind of religion thing I didn't
know yeah absolutely though they could
have gone any direction with it they
could have not included in the mat all
he could in recast who knew but it was
very very very heartwarming to have
Lance all brought back in the way that
he was and I I felt I quite quite a
strong sense of sort of commitment to to
this particular aspect of the story line
given that it is so so indicative of
such a kind of such a kind of awful
trauma to ever underwent in order to
sort of arrived where he is at now so a
lot of responsibility in a lot of
excitement and of course lancel himself
is rather committed isn't he and you
know that man branding that must've been
interesting to get that kind of branding
but on its carved into your forehead it
was interesting when we shot that on the
day I mean I mean that does the scene
itself is of all about the visuals it's
all about the sort of the sound of the
carving and this and that you know the
sort of sight of the sweat and Lee the
look of the blood but I can add a little
bit of lightheartedness to it when we
were doing that scene the audio was a
bit off so I had to go into a dr to get
the sound of having a leather sort of
strap in my mouth redone and I went into
the ad or oh man they said listen we
don't have anything that we can put in
your mouth because you suppose to be
like biting down on something we tried
paper we tried pencils and I went look
guys this is ridiculous okay we need to
find something I can use I just went
took off my belt just went look graphic
guru okay so that was that that's a
that's the lightheartedness to that
scene and I just bit down on my belts
for about a good 15 to 20 seconds so yes
that's commitment as well from you would
thank God I was wearing a belt hey it
was accidental commitment yeah and
during the scene when you were filming
as well I believe that you grew your
nails long as all for it my nails were
very very long I grew them for those few
months he's a fairly feral kind of guy
he lives in the sort of streets of
King's Landing he would most likely
sleep in a very low low down hey covered
bed it would be very you know
deliberately base and fund and not not
not vain at all and so I I made a
decision with that scene that because we
hadn't last day of shooting that we had
I basically got a got a nail clipper and
didn't cut over them but I cut
vertically into the nail and then said
to the director because he was doing a
show on hand let's just basically
squeeze the size of the wood and break
the nail on the site on the woods and we
got it and it worked and it was a small
but useful but quite nice and real bit
of footage tell me about filming that
scene where you rush into the brothel
and you take the High Septon out of
there and you will sim naked down the
streets of King's Landing well Paul Paul
Bentley would took that very very well
we made we made we made fun of the fact
that he spent all day naked we at one
point we came to episode just before
take 10 and we were about to get ready
to go and shoot and I just looked him
and just when Jesus Paul you're naked
after being having done that seen with
him about six hours so but no he's he
was really really amazing to shoot with
he was he loves all the realism behind
the violence behind the violence to to
the scene where we where he'd we dragged
him out of the brothel and he when I
when I picked him up one of the things
that we wanted to make sure we included
in that scene was that lancel is very
much involved in the physicality behind
the behind the sparrows behind that the
faith militant all the sparrows at the
time he is not it part of their ethos is
egalitarian there is no there is no high
commander even though the high Sparrow
certainly has
some degree of authority over the rest
of them they view him as more of a
spiritual leader and having any
realistic authority over them different
if you like to how the currents of the
power struggle is put down so yes no it
was great to it was anyway it was great
to work with him he's a great guy and I
felt very sorry for a dragon through the
streets naked poor guy poor guy I mean
the high Sparrow you mentioned he
started off with certain lease making
her feel and maybe some of the audience
who don't know the books field that he's
this kind of butter wouldn't melt in the
mouth carrot did he have any turn 180
degrees yeah yeah no he does he's um the
change is is quite kind of quite quite
kind of shocking to see I remember when
I read it I was sort of you know take it
as a sort of so it was quite shocked by
the way which he was presented but the
thing that makes it even more shocking
is when you start seeing the physicality
behind it so when i saw when i saw the
prosthetic for his that goes on his
forehead when we start we started
working on the the prosthetic that goes
across his his chest for when he got it
for where he got the arrow wound the
attention to detail by the makeup crew
mean they they lit they draw the most
tiny little blue bursted veins to really
like just so accurately depicted so it
was it was you feel really kind of in
the front seat of the character when you
get when you put everything on and lance
al must be feeling quite a bit of power
in the show so far because not only did
he deal with the High Septon but he also
got to drag off the Queen's brother
Laura afternoon I suppose so yeah I
suppose he does feel he does feel
empowered I I think that he then they're
they're a group that don't necessarily
pride themselves on pursuing power it's
not something that is part of their
religion but it's something that they
believe is necessary in order to to sort
of cleanse the current the current
authority of their sort of corrupt ways
really so yes he does feel power but he
views it in quite a kind of in sort of a
weird way his his actions are all very
much related back to to wanting to kind
of purge himself of his previous sin
there's a kind of that's why this this
this weird aspect of righteousness comes
into all of his
actions because he believes they almost
divinely mandated so it's a bit of a
it's a power struggle it's a it's a
psychological minefield really there's
no loss between lancelin little finger
when they saw each other this season but
what role do you think little fingers
playing in Circe's demise as munsell has
little thing has always played quite a
dangerous game from what I've seen of
the episodes and I think that he's
definitely doing that now he he's
betrayed not me traitor he's done he's
never on the side I think certainly he's
done what he does best which is
carefully coordinate the chess pieces in
this in this sort of political nightmare
and one of them just so happens to be
his knowledge of what it is that the
faith militant is really about and just
how how how much he realizes and she
does not that she falls well into the
crosshairs of who of the type of person
that we want to to purge it was
interesting why he wasn't arrested to me
when when he came when he came when
lancel came across him in King's Landing
and I think one of the sort of one of
the ways that I've unit was there's this
sort of bizarre sense of karma in
Lansing's mind that because he is such a
known figure of sin and of a flesh
peddler as he puts it the his time will
sort of come really there's this sort of
element of playing with one's food if
you know what I mean when it comes to
not arresting him because he you know he
puts his arm on him and he chooses to
let him go and I found that quite kind
of intriguing it to sort of the mystery
behind why he did that it's still
something I sort of think about from
time to time but I've you'd its kind of
karma now of course Cersei is really
getting her comeuppance this Cesar
doesn't she and a lot of people some
people enjoy watching that some people
do feel sorry for her how do you feel
about Cersei I think the moment that you
put her behind bars people start feeling
sorry for her the moment that she starts
to be at the moment that her demise
comes she receives the the the sympathy
of an audience that found her quite
difficult in the past I mean she button
but you know she does as she does have
virtues she has her she is a very loving
mother or at least she tries to be so I
think people's emotions are exactly the
way they should be in Thrones they are
mixed they are varied some people are
some people see her is
sort of getting what she deserves but I
think that the reason most people feel a
sense of sympathy Enlish essential
sympathy and and and concern for her is
because it's it's it's this isn't a slap
on the wrist she's receiving the goal is
to to utterly utterly pull the carpet
out from under her feet and create a
whole new personality at least that is
something i think that lancel is is here
to do he would be happy to see her bald
with a squid with with a seven-point
star on her forehead what are the
chances we'll see you back the season 6
and what would you like your character
to do if you are back I have I don't
know what the chances are we're gonna go
in 50 50 for now let's hope that let's
hope that he's going to come back if he
does come back well the one thing the
one thing I would say that I'm not
afraid of is dying I have no real fear
of that if he's gonna die is gonna die
and they've chosen that a long time ago
I hope he goes well I hope he goes dying
dies fighting fighting to the bitter end
for his cause but I I'm looking forward
to I'm looking I'm looking forward to
the writing primarily I'm looking
forward to what they will do with the
story line that is now gone in going
into unknown territory and I've always
really enjoyed how they have taken the
storyline how they had deviated in their
own ways from George's original
storyline I think they've done it with
tremendous sort of commitment and yet at
the same time sort of bravery and
they've taken some really big steps to
show you parts of characters that you
wouldn't have to get gotten the chance
to see in George's books to create kind
of new new emotional reactions from
characters such as Breen and the hound
and yeah I think it's wonderful what
they're doing is I'm looking forward to
seeing what they do it's been lovely
talking to you as always thank you
Eugene lovely to see you again thank you
you